Bonjour !
Comment ça va en 2019 ?
Bien ?
C'est moi, Vladimir Cagnolari qui vous
parle et je suis à Abidjan, mais en 2069 !
Le soleil cogne toujours aussi dur,
mais depuis qu'on à replanter partout des
arbres, y compris sur le toit des immeubles,
on respire...
Plus besoin de climatisation !
Et oui, on a réappris à construire en
utilisant la ventilation naturelle,
et puis surtout, on a installé en mer de
grands panneaux solaires
qui ont l'avantage de dévier l'air de l'océan
qui désormais atteint toute la ville.
Il souffle ici partout un vent léger et
doux...
C'est le vent de l'optimisme !
"Hey Djah !
On est à Abidjan la capitale les enjaillements ou quoi ?"
Mais revenons à nos cyber- moutons
et à l'Afrofuturisme que j'avais cherché à
mieux comprendre quand je vivais comme vous en 2019
Afrofuturismes !
Je vous l'avais dit,
voilà un nom qui vient d'amérique,
c'est le critique marc déry
qu'il avait inventé en 1993 pour parler
attention c'est un peu compliqué, de
fictions qui méditent sur les thèmes et les
problèmes des afro-américains, dans le
contexte de la technoculture du 20e siècle.
Ce sont donc, des créations qui s'approprient les images de la technologie.
Et d'un futur prophétiquement amélioré.
*Tchip*
Bon, tout ça là...Ça sonne un peu compliqué...
Mais, j'en ai retenu un élément dont je voudrais vous parler aujourd'hui.
En réaction à un passé et un présent
douloureux,
dominés, les afro américains ont cherché à inventer un autre futur que celui qu'on leur réservait,
et qui ressemblait trop au présent qu'il
subissait.
Alors, comment pourrait être notre futur se disaient certains, si on l'écrivait nous mêmes ?
Taillé pour nous !
Un futur où la technologie serait notre allié et plus celle qui nous asservi.
En somme, un futur plus libre !
Parce que chaque fois qu'on s'approprie son passé, ça donne un éclairage sur le présent.
Et le présent, peut nous permettre de nous projeter dans le futur.
Et non plus, uniquement dans le futur des autres !
Mais pour s'inventer un futur,
il faut savoir qui l'on est.
Et pour savoir qui l'on est
c'est bien connu il faut savoir d'où l'on vient.
En Amérique, les noirs venaient d'Afrique.
Ils savaient qu'ils descendaient des esclaves arrachés au continent,
mais cette afrique-là, elle leur avait toujours été racontée par d'autres
ceux là même qui les avait mis en
esclavage puis qui avaient colonisé le continent.
Et pour pouvoir justifier tout ça,
les européens avaient enfoncé
dans les crânes de tout le monde, y compris des africains, qu'ils avaient eux,
la civilisation et que les noires étaient des
sauvages.
Alors, pour les afro américains, il fallait retrouver cette Afrique à laquelle ils avaient été arrachés.
Celle d'avant l'esclavage,
d'avant la colonisation.
Car c'est de là au fond quils venaient !
Ces questions là,
elles hantent depuis longtemps les diasporas noires.
Et elles étaient déjà à la source,
en Jamaïque,
d'un mouvement que tout le monde connaît...
Rasta
"Africa we want to go", "nous voulons aller
en afrique", c'était un groupe du xxème siècle
qui s'appelait les "Gaylads" !
Oui le retour à l'afrique, voilà une question
qui dès le premier quart du vingtième
siècle à tarauder les diasporas
d'amérique et des caraïbes
dans une société où il était plus
esclave il n'avait pas pour autant les
mêmes droits que les blancs droits
politiques mais aussi droit à
l'éducation ou à la terre et autres
ressources économiques
alors pourquoi ne pas retourner vers
l'afrique la houle et loire était
majoritaire car l'afrique
c'était pour eux bien sûr une terre
perdue mais aussi une terre promise
à ce propos je me souviens d'une
discussion avec est l'ennemi une
journaliste française qui a passé de
longues années à comprendre des sources
du mouvement rasta bel acteur police
avait toujours été là un pour les fils
d'esclave s'était d'abord l'afrique
retourner en afrique le rêve de
l'afrique les gens du vaudou penser que
les âmes des africains morts dans le
nouveau monde retourner en afrique donc
il ya toujours eu en filigrane ce rêve
de l'afrique de l'ethiopie comme on
disait à l'époque on disait pas la
friandise et l'ethiopie qui désigne à
toute l'afrique ayant tout à fait le
pays des défis sage paul et comme on dit
l'ethiopie à l'époque s'appelait
abyssinie donc il ya toujours eu cette
présence de l'afrique dans le rêve noirs
américains en fait c'est un retour
virtuel culturelle bien sûr il y avait
des moments il ya eu à cette époque
énormément de tentatives de retourner en
afrique de coloniser l'afrique marcus
garvey a beaucoup travaillé un projet
avec le liberia en particulier il a
envoyé un des gens essayer de mettre au
point
une recolonisation de l'afrique par les
noirs du nouveau monde dans que ce désir
de retourner à faire le pays des pères a
toujours été extrêmement puissant c'est
une faute
marcus garvey c'est justement un des
piliers de ce mouvement du retour né en
jamaïque en 1887 il atterrit aux états
unis où il fonde lumia l'union pour
l'amélioration de la condition noire
il crée aussi son journal de newell's et
entreprendre même de lancer une
compagnie maritime la black star line
pour permettre le rapatriement des noirs
du nouveau monde vers la maison vers
l'afrique
un des contemporains de marcus garvey
s'appelle leonard howell
lui aussi est né en jamaïque et après
avoir fait le tour du monde en
travaillant comme marin il s'installe à
new york c'est d'ailleurs là qu'il
croisera marcus garvey dans les années
1920 à l'époque harlem est en pleine
ébullition culturelles et les églises
noires elles aussi rêve d'afrique
et oui pour les noirs du nouveau monde
la bible est devenu le livre de
référence souvent d'ailleurs le seul
autorisé du temps de l'esclavagé voilà
pourquoi ils se reconnaissent dans la
destinée du peuple de l'exode
exodus ou quand les hébreux quittent
l'egypte pour s'installer sur la terre
promise
sion ou encore zion les psaumes eux
aussi prennent une autre résonance comme
le psaume 137 que les rastas reprendront
en continu sur les rives des fleuves de
babylone nous étions assis et nous
pleurions on nous
non de sion la chine aux vainqueurs nous
demandaient les champs et nos
oppresseurs de la joie à les chanter
nous quelques-uns des cantiques de sion
mais comment on chante aurions-nous les
cantiques de l'éternel sur une terre
étrangère
m
ok
là
les mélodieuse un groupe de jamaïque
reprenait ce bon vieux psaumes chantés
dans les églises gospel et parler un
star leonardo wayne le compatriote de
marcus garvey lui aussi installé aux
états unis baigne donc dans cette
atmosphère où la bible tient lieu
d'outils de résistance cette même bible
ne dit elle pas que l'ethiopie tendre à
ses mains vers dieu à l'époque des
traducteurs grecque
le moa ethiopia désignait toute
l'afrique et en ce début du 20e siècle
il existe bel et bien un pays qui
s'appelle les copies et qui n'a jamais
été colonisé
mieux il a infligé une cinglante défaite
aux armées italiennes aa doit en 1896 et
pour couronner le tout les souverains
éthiopien 10 des cendres de l'union de
la reine éthiopienne de saba et du roi
salomon de jérusalem 1930
quant aux elle entend un jour cargo fort
bien d'être couronné en ethiopie le
rastafari pouvoir de la trinité en
amharique il décide d'en faire sont
souvent entrés en jamaïque il fonde une
communauté autonome dans l'économie
baptisé le pinacle lorsque eau l air en
train jamaïque ce qu'il disait c'est pas
il ya un nouveau dieu il est noir il
s'appelle hailé sélassié ce qu'il disait
c'est vous n'êtes pas des anglais vous
êtes des africains vous avez souffert
parce que vous n'aviez aucun
gouvernement pour vous représenter
dorénavant vous êtes les citoyens d'une
grande nation qui s'appelle le
l'abyssinie ou l'ethiopie et maintenant
si vous avez un problème
adressez-vous hailé sélassié il peut
vous défendre parce que c'est lui votre
roi s'était pas forcément une position
littéral bah si c'est justement cette
venue littérale et c'est ça qui a créé
le problème parce que tant qu'il disait
comme marcus garvey chacun peut voir
dieu par ses propres lunettes et nous
les verrons par les lunettes de
l'afrique ça allait c'était abstrait
c'était vague mais ce que disait oh well
c'était beaucoup plus grave
c'était ne payez pas les taxes à charge
vous n'êtes pas des citoyens de ce pays
vous êtes des citoyens de l'ethiopie et
si vous payer des taxes et à moi qui
représente deux souverains et dieu bien
donc ça ça faisait très peur
et du coup ça faisait prendre conscience
au genre du fait que à partir du moment
où il aurait un endroit où on ne pouvait
plus venir les attaques et il serait
totalement débarrassé de babylone
débarrasser de l' esclavage débarrasser
de la déco néo-colonisation donc cette
prise de conscience est essentielle et
c'est ça je pense qui a créé d'identité
rasta par contre ensuite la population
jamaïcaine très pauvre à la caisse de se
dresser
c'était des gens qui comme tout livre
que ne connaissait que la bible est donc
forcément ils ont transposé leur
structure mentale religieuse sur ce que
leur disais oh elle est donc petit à
petit ils ont fait de ces l'acier un
dieu vivant etc et vote
oh
on veut divinity c'est la sieste
chapelle ça c'était bob marley en mode
cantiques religieux mais vous savez on
surnommait le roi du reggae tuff gong et
ses studios en jamaïque porte encore ce
nom c'est une référence à leonardo well
justement qui se faisait appeler le gong
et qui fut à n'en pas douter le premier
rasta le premier instinct c'est le titre
d'un livre d'hélène ni que je vous
invite à lire et que l'on retrouve
toujours en 2069 ici à abidjan dans la
bibliothèque tiken jah fakoly de
yopougon
et
en tout cas voilà comment naît la pensée
rasta à la fois spirituelle et
politiques haïlé sélassié quant à lui
offrira des terres aura stareo diaspora
en ethiopie sur laquelle certains
d'ailleurs non sans difficultés sont
allés s'installer pour vivre ce qui
était au départ un rêve une utopie une
afro tpi même née de l'expérience noire
est devenue universelle grâce au
concours du reggae c'est quoi même le
rapport avec la futaie 10 mhz et bien
c'est qu'il y avait dans cette utopie
rasta un élément qu'on va retrouver dans
l'afro futurisme se reconstruire c'est
d'abord se reconstruire une histoire
réelle du mythique pour imaginer un
avenir débarrassé de toute oppression et
là c'est cette même idée qu'on va
retrouver alors que la lutte pour les
droits civiques pas son plein chez les
auteurs et des penseurs afro-américains
et eux c'est dans le futur qu'ils
chercheront leur ailleurs et leur
émancipation
mais avant de continuer il faut quand
même que je vous raconte ce que je fais
à abidjan en 2069 ou plutôt comment je
suis arrivé là moi qui comme vous ai
vécu dans les années 2010 qui est connu
l'arrivée au pouvoir de barack obama
puis de donald trump le départ forcé de
robert mugabe et qui est même vécu le
passage en 2010
j'étais justement en train de faire mon
enquête façon façon sur la trop
futurisme et à force de me projeter dans
le futur de lire des romans de science
fiction
et bien j'en ai fini par en rêver la
nuit la nuit c'est bien connu le cerveau
continue d'être très actif du moins
certaines zones et là je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est passé j'ai entendu comme des
interférences et je voyais des
scientifiques bizarre - billet qui me
regardait dormir sur un écran il touché
à plein de boutons parler entre eux en
code avec quelques mots de français de
nos chine où tout à coup ils se sont mis
à me parler à travers l'écran genève ont
trouvé clairement et je me souviens que
moi aussi je leur parle la dernière
chose que j'ai entendu c'est ça marche
on le télécharge je n'ai pas eu le temps
de comprendre ce qui se passait mais je
me suis réveillé dans leurs labos ils
m'ont fait bon accueil
j'étais la preuve que leur expérience
avait fonctionné puis comme je me
trouvais pas si mal dans le futur j'ai
décidé de rester
de temps en temps je croise quelqu'un
qui a été téléchargé comme moi et on
partage notre étonnement devant ce que
le monde est devenu en 2069 ça pourrait
bien vous arrivez à vous aussi qui c'est
bon mais revenons à nos histoires afro
futuriste et aux états unis
je parlais des rastas comme une
expérience pionnière mais après eux il y
avait eu un penseur qui a eu une grande
influence sur les intellectuels et
artistes afro-américains et il est
africain c'est les chercheurs sénégalais
cheikh anta diop
quand on parle de mes diplômes parle
d'un rien l'egypte s'est pas lorient oui
c'est bien cheikh anta diop qui a remis
l'egypte antique celle qui a tant
fasciné et épater les occidentaux là où
elle se trouve c'est à dire en afrique
alors pas seulement sur la carte
géographique mais aussi sur celle de la
culture de la langue de la religion
l'egypte antique était résolument
africaine martelait-il et elle était
noir
pour tous ceux auxquels on avait
enseigné que l'afrique n'était pas entré
dans l'histoire eh bien c'était une
révolution
évidemment mon ami le vieux père binda
ngazolo lui aussi était fan
il a suffi d'un seul check intalio
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autre prétention
que celle d'émettre une hypothèse qu'on
donne tout le monde m'est tombé dessus
ça même quand le zen quand même et le
bloc était quand même contemporain de
ces gens dit il les aide des clips une
certaine façon champollion arrive après
commence à dire ni les essais et c'est
le point de vue des championnats qui
s'installe et qui fait autorité
si cheikh anta diop n'avait pas fait ce
travail là s'il avait baissé les bras
parce que tout le monde devait tomber du
sud y compris saint maur qui fait que
les pharaons était noir oui et alors si
les vestiges de l'egypte ancienne c'est
tout en afrique et qui sait tous que
dans cette afrique il ya des noirs ya
peut-être des chances que tu essaies
africain l'a élu quelque chose à voir
avec ces vestiges là le fait que les
anciens égyptiens et des peignoirs nous
éprouvée par plusieurs témoignages les
grès à l'époque classique qui n'avait
aucun intérêt
à nous présenter le gie lui tient sous
entend jouer cnis
nous faisons toujours décrits comme
étant des noirs c'est le cas des robes
qui a visité l'egypte à une époque
d'ailleurs où l'egypte a perdu son
indépendance
c'était sous les perses à -4 155 hervé a
visité l'egypte il a pu noter les
égyptiens étaient des noirs alors revu
et explique que c'était les vestiges de
ses talents de ses garnisons de ces au
styliste c'est à dire de toute mon
histoire
cheikh anta diop nous a sauvé la vie il
nous a sauvé les imaginaires il nous a
donné des motifs de pas juste de fierté
tu vois que c'est juste 2 il nous a
redonné notre part d'humanité nous a
juste permis de nous réapproprier notre
part d'humanité
il dira que nous étions là au même titre
que les autres ni plus ni moins parce
que chaque fois qu'on s'approprie son
passé ça donne un éclairage sur le
présent et le présent peut nous
permettre de nous projeter dans le futur
et non plus uniquement dans le futur des
autres voilà c'est bien travail que fait
cheikh anta diop et son premier article
publié en europe en 1948 annonçait déjà
son programme il s'intitulait quand
pourra-t-on assister à une renaissance
africaine l'afrique était la mère de
l'humanité nous ancêtres étaient tous
noirs et avant les siècles de chaos
qu'elle a suivi et bien l'afrique était
aussi le berceau des grandes
civilisations
à commencer donc par celle de l'egypte
celle là même du cheikh anta diop qui a
enseigné ces savoirs au crec la
référence cardinal des européens les
gars étaient très fiers de dire qu'ils
sont allés s'inscrit en egypte pour dire
qu'ils sont devenus des savants comme
les africains nous sommes aujourd'hui
soit fier de dire que nous on était un
des études à londres ou à paris ou à
berlin
alors voilà quel est l apport il n'est
arrivé à aucun moment à la grèce l'idée
de se comparer
l'egypte est justement même la grèce
n'est ce pas de l'époque classique à
conduire à venir et l'egypte et c'est
cela qui frappe aujourd'hui
l'imagination des spécialistes et c'est
cela qu'ils veulent nier
vous ne pouvez pas tout mais dans le
texte grec de l'époque classique une
contestation de l'egypte en tant que
maire les sciences au contraire j'adore
les 6 il a suffisamment montré wave à
plat suffisamment montré estragon parle
également de même des grecs célèbres qui
ont fait un stage en egypte qu on plaque
en inox d'alès qui a introduit la
géométrie en grèce est allé s'inscrire
en egypte d'après la tradition grecque
même pythagore également il y est resté
21 comme je vous le disais démocrite
tous les grands savants grecs se sont
inscrits à l'époque ptolémaïque ils vont
venir tous installés à alexandrie
comment expliquer cela parce que
l'egypte offrait une infrastructure
scientifique que c'est elle possédait à
l'époque même l'egypte qui a cessé
d'être indépendantes continuent de
l'autre tonton que je vous ai déjà
présenté lors de ma dernière
transmission
le prof souleymane bachir diagne a vu
l'impact que la pensée de cheikh anta
diop avait eu dans les milieux
artistiques et intellectuels américains
inspirant par exemple des musiciens
comme pharoah sanders ou sonnera dont je
vous reparlerai bientôt
il est père de ce que l'on appelle aussi
d'antennes qui
change beaucoup de signification
afrocentrisme l'idée de
la fiq centrée sur elle-même et qui a
son propre centre comme l'europe avait
décidé que son centre c'était la
civilisation de la comparaison
c'est vrai qu'il ya de cela un peu
l'egypte joué à ce moment là par rapport
à l'histoire africaine
le rôle que la grèce a joué pour
l'histoire européenne c'est une espèce
de mimétisme qui est une réaction à la
négation coloniale et à l'animation la
cistude jeudi je parlais tout à l'heure
de la l'image d'une afrique lot
constitué pour les africains américains
et c'est vrai que l'egypte occupe une
place énorme mais une jupe noire il y
est un territoire qui fait rêver qui est
à la fois un territoire qui fait rêver
par la technologie qu'on soupçonne
qu'elle avait on ne sait toujours pas au
fond ces pyramides
quelle technique on a pu les installer
donc il y à une projection y compris de
la science fiction sur l'egypte ou
peut-être ce sont des extraterrestres
qui serait venu à un moment donné qui
aurait enseigné aux égyptien d'alors
l'art des pyramides ou que construit
eux-mêmes les pyramides
donc n'oubliez l'egypte ici est à la
fois une sorte d'histoire première et
mystérieuse de l'humanité et l'humanité
noir donc dans le dans le cadre de la
66ème et également un lieu de ou à
partir duquel on peut projeter une
histoire future ça va reprendre donc du
coup sur le plan même de la science
fiction
l'egypte va également occuper notre
place et donc voilà la signification me
semble t'il du travail de cheikh anta
diop pour les africains américains parce
que celle toute sa vie a été consacrée à
restituer l'histoire de l'égypte à
l'histoire du continent africain et à
rectifier cette reconstruction que l'on
doit pour l'essentiel à eagle au
philosophe allemand hegel et qui lui
m et contemporain des premiers à la
manifestation du colonialisme puisque il
donne ses grandes leçons celle du sceau
de la philosophie autour de 1830 qui est
l'année de la conquête d'alger par la
france qu'il salue d'ailleurs il salue
cela comme allant dans le sens de
l'histoire et ce n'est pas un hasard si
lui d'épaisses complètement la fig en
disant l'egypte peut se trouver
accidentellement géographiquement sur le
continent africain
mais la civilisation égyptienne
appartient l'asie et donc c'était une
manière de ramener d'égypte en afrique
est de dire que l'histoire de l'egypte
ne se comprend pas son histoire de la
totalité du continent il s'était
d'ailleurs l'egypte a été nourrie par
son sud
donc cet aspect des choses explique au
fond l'importance qu'il a eue pour une
tradition qu'on appellera à fond sans
tri de ce point de vue là qui s'est
développé beaucoup chez les africains
américains
on le verra l'egypte ayant retrouvé
l'afrique c'est dieu et ses pyramides
vont avoir une longue destinée dans
l'afro futurisme
certains y verront même et c'est ce que
disait le provincial ya l'instant la
preuve que les pharaons noirs et leurs
techniques venait d'une autre planète et
leur descendance aussi la
science-fiction afro-américaine
s'approche à grand pas et d'après binda
elle est pétrie de morceaux d'imaginaire
venus d'afrique ce que nous avons
précisément un partage
ce sont ces imaginaires c'est là où pu
voir la force des spiritualités
parce que malgré les cinq siècles des
dégâts que nous avons subies il est
quand même hallucinant de voir à quel
point on retrouve ces imaginaires
intacte dans les amériques du nord
compte du sud à des niveaux différents
évidemment nous on retrouve les mêmes
personnages exemple exemple le vaudou
dans les sentiers à cuba et de l'idée de
ces humains qui auraient la capacité à
vivre de vie vivre de vie là visible et
l'invisible
on n'est pas loin la du réel et du
virtuel une distinction créée par les
nouvelles technologies
quant au vaudou cette religion du golfe
de guinée
et qu'on retrouve en haïti au brésil ou
à cuba eh bien elle était présente aussi
aux états unis notamment à la nouvelle
orléans une ville qui est le berceau du
jazz et qui sert de cadre un roman
délirant que je vous recommande mon beau
djombo de l'écrivain afro-américains
ishmael reid une fiction écrite dans les
années 1970 et dont l'histoire se
déroule elle dans les années 1900 elle
raconte comment just go le virus du jazz
de la danse et de la transe gagne le
pays et serait pas en cause de
l'épidémie
l'activité de jaws groulx ne se dément
pas 800 cas dénombrés depuis la nuit
dernière
immédiatement isolés dans des
baraquements édifié par la jeunesse
chrétienne
les jeunes sont particulièrement touchés
on annonce des poussées de fièvre à
saint paul minnesota wild boars
pennsylvanie de grands rassemblements se
forme autour des personnes déjà
contaminées
reprenant tous en choeur nous voulons la
fièvre nous voulons la fièvre cette
épidémie les autorités américaines
tentent de la contenir avec l'aide de
confréries secrètes qui manipulent
amérique et veillent au maintien de
l'ordre blanc leur bras armé les membres
de l'ordre de la fleur de murailles qui
tentent d'infiltrer les milieux noir au
moyen d'un android pour les détourner de
just go mais certains afro descendants
qui maîtrise le vaudou s'oppose-t-elle
parmi eux a pas là bas un prêtre vaudou
qui recherchent le livre sacré qui
libérera le just go il s'agit d'un
manuscrit écrit en lire aux glyphes
égyptien tiens tiens il a pour allié
objectif des rebelles haïtiens mais
aussi les moutafis cas qui sévissent
dans les musées les moutafis cas ce sont
dans le livre des chemins louis ide des
sorte de robin des bois qui ont décidé
de rendre à leur propriétaire les
oeuvres d'art et autres objets rituels
qui ont été pillées par les occidentaux
les voici qui se réunissent justement
extrême
m
une réunion d moutafis cas se tient dans
le sous sol d'un immeuble de trois
étages à la limite de la ville chinoise
au rez de chaussée est installé un
magasin d'articles religieux vous dessus
une armurerie et au troisième étage une
agence de publicité spécialisée dans la
promotion de lessive sa modeste bâtiment
des années 20 au fret en quelque sorte
sur trois étages et un sous-sol un
saisissant raccourci de la civilisation
occidentale
un groupe de moutafis casse à faire il
emballé avec soin des objets d'art
destinés à être envoyés à leurs agents
dans les îles du pacifique
ce dernier se chargera de la
réexpédition aux propriétaires légitimes
en asie tam musiciens et écrivains venus
du niger s'occupe pour sa part du retour
en afrique de cinq mille masques en bois
sculpté son premier exploit fut
l'enlèvement d'une plaque de bronze du
bénin au linden muséum de stuttgart puis
à la tête d'un petit groupe se faisant
passer pour des étudiants en voyage
d'étude il s'attaqua au butin amassé en
europe avant que les directeurs des
musées américains aient pu prévenir
leurs collègues de l'ancien monde
le commando libérait des centaines de
figurines de statuettes de masques
enlevés au nigeria la côte de l'or à la
haute volta à la côte d'ivoire est
enfermé dans ses repaires de pirates que
l' on baptise musée mombo jumbo dis-je
mais lui il est paru en 1972
voilà un livre débordant d'imagination
ça vous l'aurez compris qu'ils ne se
projette pas exactement dans le futur
encore qu'il ya des éléments qui sortent
du futur qui se retrouvent dans les
années 20 mais qui revisite plutôt
l'histoire américaine
en redonnant aux résistances noir la
part qui fut la leur et à l'afrique son
influence à l'heure où je vous parle en
2069 rishmawi d' à sa statue dans les
principales villes du bénin d'haïti et
bien sûr aux états unis où je vous
emmène pour ma prochaine transmission là
là je dois vous laisser parce que j'ai
rendez vous chez mon herboriste le
docteur faye à l'agessa l'hôpital
général des savoirs de l'afrique un bon
rien de grave mais j'ai quand même
parfois des trous de mémoire à cause du
décalage temporel
et j'écoute boulot